so you guys
put together that first Weezer album
and it's a huge success that's the time
that I encounter you
and
were you
was that a do you remember that now is
like a really happy time some people
have a hard time digesting that kind of
success you know it was it's a huge it
was a huge deal
yeah I don't I don't know if that was
particular to our generation but it
seemed like a whole lot of bands tried
their best to to make it and when they
finally made it they became very
miserable and felt like this was the
last thing they wanted
and uh I don't know if that still
happens to young young artists but it
seemed like it happened to a lot of ours
did happen to you guys yeah I after a
year on tour I was like screw this and I
went back to college
that's right uh it's and and with the
thing that you hated about it was
touring repetition
um being on a bus you know that kind of
stuff yeah it was just it was utterly
mind-numbing and and boring and um just
singing the same songs over and over and
there's tons of travel packing unpacking
and none of it was interesting
um and I just craved some kind of
intellectual stimulation so I went back
to school
um you and I are at the same College
different times but you went to you so
you you applied to Harvard when when
you're already a rock star is that
correct yeah we were on tour and with
you know I hit out a monster Hit album
yeah and you decide and this is what a
lot of rock stars do they have a monster
hit and they say you know what I think
it's time to apply to an Ivy League
school
yeah we were we were playing Boston so I
I just went up to the campus and got an
application and filled it out and I
couldn't believe it but they accepted me
um
yeah I think there's a lot of people
right now going wait what
I went in it's like you applied for a
job at CVS so you you get accepted and
suddenly you're at Harvard don't people
know that oh [ __ ] that guy over there
who's in my ec10 class and who I just
saw getting veal parmesan at the Adams
House dining room
that's he's a rock star did they know
not until the last day of school
uh because most of our fans at that time
were like 10 years old literally we we
connected to a very young
uh group of kids and uh
it wasn't really like a college audience
right
also it's kind of hard to remember but
at that time there was no sense of like
me as the front man or like famous or
anything it was more people knew the
name Weezer and they knew a couple songs
but that was about it
and I grew a very long beard and long
hair and I I had I was undergoing this
this uh procedure on my leg that so I
was walking with a cane I just looked
like some really weird super old weird
guy that why is he in this class
you know I'd be riding the bus with with
uh with other students that were wearing
Weezer shirts that didn't even you know
they had no idea I just love that wow
you'd be on a bus at Harvard as a as a
student uh and people are wearing Weezer
shirts and they don't know that you have
any connection to that band
yeah so on the last day of school after
after the full year
um in my music class I remember
one you know it was having a
conversation with some other kids and
one one of them said so so what are you
doing for the summer
I was like uh I think we're going on
tour with no doubt and uh
oh cool are you working on a tour or
something and no no I'm in Weezer and
that you know mines were blown at that
moment that's right and they're like so
you're a roadie for Weezer like no
you're the accountant no